et qu'une catastrophe est tout à fait
déplorable on a vu des personnes
gravement blessées on a entendu aussi le
terme violences policières ce débat sur
les violences policières ce qu'il a
toujours existé il a toujours existé la
première grande manifestation parisienne
du 6 février 34 on a même pu craindre la
disparition de la toute jeune garde
républicaine billes dans la presse
s'était déchaînée sur ce qu'était
réellement le noyau dur du dispositif de
maintien d'ordre à l'époque
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes en sang comme
chaque soir du lundi au jeudi jusqu'à
21h30 pour décrypter les grands titres
de l'actualité de la journée au sommaire
de ce mercredi 10 novembre
beaucoup de réactions au lendemain de
l'allocution d'emmanuel microns
l'opposition dénonce un discours de
campagne après l'annnonce de quelques
mesures anti qu'ovide la majeure partie
de sa prise de parole a été consacrés à
son bilan et aux réformes à venir sont
même se déclarer pouvoir d'achat
retraite assurance chômage et nucléaire
le chef de l'état at il fait une entrée
en campagne par la droite en attend vos
réactions sur le conte télégramme
berthet france
dans sa prise de parole le chef de
l'état qui s'est aussi félicité de sa
politique en faveur de la jeunesse grâce
aux blancs un jeune une solution 3
millions de jeunes ont pu trouver une
formation un emploi ou un accompagnement
selon lui mais quelle est la réalité sur
le terrain les jeunes sont ils d'accord
avec le diagnostic positif du président
et notamment les étudiants frappé
durement par la crise sanitaire dans
notre rubrique qu'en pensent les
financer ce soir nous sommes allés à la
rencontre d'une étudiante de 19 ans qui
a du mal à joindre les deux bouts
l'estonie la france et l'irlande demande
ce soir une réunion d'urgence du conseil
de sécurité de l'onu en cause les
milliers migrants bloqués à la frontière
entre la biélorussie et la pologne une
situation intolérable pour l'onu alors
que le premier ministre polonais accuse
minsk de terrorisme d'état la
biélorussie estime que l'union
européenne se sert de ce prétexte pour
lui imposer de nouvelles sanctions
pour le kremlin varsovie se montre
irresponsable de l'accusé de cette crise
migratoire
facebook est-il un véritable danger pour
le monde auditions de frances hogen
devant les députés et sénateurs français
aujourd'hui la lanceuse alerte
américaine poursuit sa tournée en europe
dans le cadre de ces révélations sur le
fonctionnement interne du réseau social
l'ex employé de facebook accuse le géant
du web de privilégier le profit au
détriment de la sécurité on attend vos
réactions sur le compte d g verte et
france et on ouvre le débat à 21h
[Musique]
l'allocution d'emmanuel macro hier soir
a provoqué une avalanche de réactions
tout au long de la journée des critiques
notamment de l'opposition qui dénonce un
discours du chef de l'état en campagne à
cinq mois de la présidentielle sans être
candidat déclaré pour autant on en parle
tout de suite avec notre reporter nadège
à des rasades devant l'elysée bonsoir
nadège alors cette allocution
o qui embarrasse entre autres les ténors
de la droite qui parlent de tentatives
de hold up sur leurs idées
hier j'ai entendu un candidat à la
présidence de la république est les mots
sont signés de gérard larcher président
l ère du sénat et une fois n'est pas
coutume à l'ensemble de l'opposition est
du même avis nucléaire retraite travail
à droite on accuse le président de la
république d'avoir pioché dans le
programme des républicains de l'élection
présidentielle de 2000 22 à valérie
pécresse présidente de la région ile de
france candidate à l'investiture
lr parle même de tentative de hold-up
est coupée
il y a eu clairement une
instrumentalisation de la crise qu vide
pour faire un discours de campagne
puisque on l'a bien vu emmanuel macron
est candidat il a fait une tentative de
hold up sur les idées de la droite le
travail le nucléaire les retraites mais
c'est une nouvelle fois vouée à l'échec
il a regardé le débat des républicains
c'est évident mais ça ne trompe personne
même son de cloche du côté du
rassemblement national marine le pen se
moque d'un président de la république je
cite qui vivent dans un monde parallèle
la troisième dose n'aura donc été qu'une
excuse pour faire un discours de
campagne dont presque toutes les
déclarations sont éminemment contestable
chômage insécurité pouvoir d'achat le
monde parallèle des manuels macron est
loin des réalités que vivent les
français et nadège à gauche on ironise
en invitant le président à rejoindre les
as l'air
absolument alors pour jean luc mélenchon
emmanuel macron s'est présenté comme un
candidat président ou comme un président
candidat il a d'ailleurs déploré le fait
que son temps de parole ne soit pas
décomptés comme tels jean luc mélenchon
estime qu'il ya de plus en plus de
points communs entre le président de la
république et les républicains jean luc
mélenchon qui invite le président de la
république à rejoindre tout bonnement le
parti de la droite
clairement emmanuel macron est candidat
et son temps de parole n'est pas
décompté comme tel il mélange les genres
d'une manière anormale il agit comme
candidat président emmanuel macron parle
d' angoisses et dit qu'il faut avoir
confiance en nous mêmes mais c'est lui
qui accroît les angoisses en s'en
prenant aux droits des chômeurs et en
disant qu'il va falloir travailler plus
longtemps les républicains peuvent
arrêter leur congrès ils ont déjà leur
candidat
sans surprise sein de la majorité
présidentielle ont fait bloc derrière le
président de la république et gabriel
attal a défendu le président de la
république il a répondu aux critiques
après cette neuvième allocution
télévisée d'emmanuel macron depuis le
début de la pandémie le porte parole du
gouvernement a estimé qu'il était normal
que le président elle s'exprime sur tous
les sujets qui sont au coeur de la vie
et des inquiétudes des français qui plus
est dans un contexte de crise historique
fin de citation
abderrazak alors vous qu'en pensez-vous
emmanuel macron fait-il une entrée en
campagne par la droite on attend
toujours vos réactions sur le compteur
télégramme d'ayrté france place
maintenant au décryptage
[Musique]
avec nous sur ce plateau pour en parler
jean didier berthault conseiller l'air à
la mairie de paris dans le 17ème
arrondissement vous êtes l'un des porte
parole de xavier bertrand candidat à la
présidentielle bonsoir jean didier
berthault merci d'être avec nous à vos
côtés thomas porte parole national de
génération s merci à vous d'être là
aussi bon soir thomas porte alors
emmanuel macron qui a donc parlé de
sauter d'économie de social de
géopolitique un petit peu hier soir un
mot tout d'abord un sur son discours car
le travail était hier soir rarement au
coeur de ses préoccupations il a parlé
en point et surtout de réforme de
l'assurance chômage on propose de
l'écouter
pôle emploi passera en revue les
centaines de milliers d'offres d'emploi
disponibles sans réponse dès les
prochaines semaines les demandeurs
d'emploi qui ne démontreront pas une
recherche active verront leurs
allocations suspendues
alors c'était important de vous faire
entendre cette france parce que ça c'est
plutôt un thème clairement à droite il
vous piquer un de vos thèmes la droite
en rêvait emmanuel macron le fait ou va
le faire on sait pas trop envie de
liberté moi j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
deux français illustre qui sont revenus
de l'espace hier il ya thomas pesquet il
ya le président de la république c'est
absolument incroyable de d'entendre un
discours comme on a pu l'entendre
pendant plus de 20 minutes qu'il était
absolument pas consacré d'ailleurs à la
situation sanitaire pas plus que cinq
minutes pour ensuite développer des
thèmes de campagne pour le président est
en campagne tout le monde l'a compris
maintenant sa crédibilité pour nous
annoncer trois mois avant les élections
ce qu'il n'a pas fait pendant cinq ans
tout le monde aura compris qu'elle est
très limité alors on a entendu à gauche
ans
on avait tendance à avoir envie de
conseiller emmanuel macron de rejoindre
les leurs c'est votre avis aussi thomas
porte vous avez fait des bonds sur votre
canapé hier soir devant votre télé mais
pas des bons mais ça a confirmé la ligne
politique des moniales macron qui est
celle de s'attaquer aux plus précaires
et vous avez parlé de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage on avait
l'impression de revoir le président qui
disait ce qu'il a dit à l'époque
c'est-à-dire traverser la rue pour
trouver un emploi c'est un président en
campagne qui est en fait un discours de
campagne alors que l'allocution était
prévu sur les mesures sanitaires et la
gestion de la crise de duke au vide on a
eu trois mots là-dessus et pas un mot
sur l'hôpital public d'ailleurs que dans
une situation absolument que tu as
trophée ici il a dit qu'il y ait un
maximum pour les soignants
jamais on n'avait fait autant pour
justement
il ya aussi un sujet sur l'intervention
du chef de l'état puisque dire c'est un
discours de candidat et on avait
personne pour le contredire il comprit
pas de journaliste pour lui poser des
questions sauf qu emmanuel macron ces 4
milliards en moins dans le budget de
l'hôpital public depuis 2000 17 cd
souvenir à bout de souffle c'est des
fermetures de lits y compris pendant qu
vide donc voilà ce que c'est emmanuel
macron et la politique de santé mais
hier c'était un discours à droite et je
t'aime président de droite donc il est
cohérent avec ce qu'il porte depuis le
début de son quinquennat jean didier
berthault même analyse que thomas porte
finalement il n'a pas tellement évolué
emmanuel macron il était de droite à
l'origine
toujours autant non s'il était si
l'évolution six lycées droite il
obtiendrait des résultats et est ce que
je ressens surtout dans dans le led son
intervention d'hier c'est une erreur
aussi par rapport à la stratégie de
lutte contre la pandémie ce qui est
important pour nous aujourd'hui en
france face à cette reprise potentielle
de la pandémie c'est obtenir des
résultats sur la vaccination c'est avoir
de la clarification sur le pass and it r
c'est effectivement avoir des mesures
sur l'hôpital public et aujourd'hui
enfin en tout cas hier soir on n'a pas
eu ça on a eu des mesures qui était
politique et qui peuvent aller même à
contresens du résultat espéré parce que
si vous êtes par exemple contre le
nucléaire est ce que vous allez vous
faire vacciner par rapport à la parole
présidentielle est ce que ya pas une
confusion dans tout ça est ce que
finalement le but le but recherché n'est
pas l' inverse du résultat obtenu alors
on va on va regarder les premières
réactions sur le comté d g d'ayrté
france la première qui nous dit mais ne
mettront veut séduire une partie de la
droite on le voit bien il fit les idées
des dlr se doit vous faire plaisir en
achetant son allocution lundi prochain
après le deuxième débat d'ailleurs
effectivement vous pensez vraiment qu'il
est votre programme sur sa table de nuit
emmanuel macron bas en tout cas on voit
visiblement qu'il se nourrit des idées
donc c'est très bien on apporte des
idées au pays on vend les appliquera et
jeu c'est pour ça que j'attends après
chaque débat une allocution du président
maintenant alors deuxième remarque mais
la vie qui nous dit la gauche aux
fraises la droite dans le peloton de
tête en tout cas dans les sondages
macron pas folle la guêpe en gros est ce
qu'il a ce que c'est pas finalement
assez malin de la part du président de
la république aujourd'hui de se
positionner à droite pour la siphonné
une nouvelle fois et et tenter de
remporter cette présidentielle thomas
porte ça nous inquiète alors j'imagine
qu'on aime ça nous inquiète pas parce
que ce que je dis au départ emmanuel
macron il et mène une politique de
droite depuis qu'il a été élu et
aujourd'hui il conduit 2 me de mener
cette politique là et je crois que l'on
n'est qu'un dans un pays aujourd'hui qui
traverse une crise économique sanitaire
et sociale d'une ampleur inégalée on
était aujourd'hui sur la journée
mondiale de la précarité énergétique on
a 12 millions de précaires énergie et le
président emmanuel macron vieira ciblée
les chômeurs à simuler les jeunes comme
si ces gens là étaient responsables de
leur propre situation moi je vous
rappelle une chose sur les chômeurs
parce qu'on les a montrées beaucoup du
doigt hier et gabriela talent a rappelé
ce matin qu'ils allaient accélérer les
contrôles mais dans ce pays a qu'un
chômeur sur deux qui n'est pas
indemnisée il ya une âme isation moyen
de 900 euros et c'est aujourd'hui la
dares dit qu'il ya treize fois plus de
chômeurs que d'emplois disponibles donc
posons nous la question de pourquoi ces
gens ne reviennent par l'emploi la
qualité de l'emploi fournit la qualité
des salaires donc c'est toujours pareil
à manier la cre ont fait la chasse au
chômage et non pas au choix fait la
chasse aux chômeurs pardon une ombre au
chômage donc c'est absolument scandaleux
et c'est la dernière pierre à l'édifice
de la réforme de l'assurance chômage qui
va pour certains allocataires se
traduire par une baisse de quasiment 40
% des ados jean didier berthault pour
revenir sur cette dernière remarque
qu'on a vu on peut dire voilà ils nous
piquent nos idées et puis s'en plaindre
il n'empêche c'est une stratégie qui a
déjà marché dans le passé est ce que
vous avez peur aux choses aujourd'hui
que ça refonctionne non les électeurs
sont pas des imbéciles si ça
fonctionnait il ya cinq ans et qui a eu
aucun résultat et la france est
aujourd'hui encore plus fracturées
qu'elle ne l'était il ya cinq ans c'est
pas pour impliquer les mêmes vieilles
recettes donc aujourd'hui monsieur macro
nous explique que la sécurité est
importante déjà mis autant d'insécurité
nous explique que le nucléaire c'est
important il à fermer fessenheim enfin
bon un moment donné si vous voulez il
faut quand même juste lui rappeler son
bilan et puis voir qui est crédible pour
appliquer les nouvelles mesures qui
seront pour les cinq prochaines années
c'est évident a tant apporté clairement
comme la météo emmanuel macron hier il
ya la température elle et il ya le
ressenti tout au long de discours c'est
ce que vous avez pu ressentir comme
beaucoup de français je crois qu'il ya
eu un décalage entre effectivement ce
que porte emmanuel macron et le ressenti
des français dans le pays où aujourd'hui
son bilan il le traîne quelque part
qu'on aime boulet puisqu'il ya un
mécontentement qui est extrêmement
important la sécurité notamment qu'est
ce que vous en pensez vous dit voilà on
est dans une france plus sûre moins de
cambriolages ou un génération s quel est
votre a baissé de 7,1
une accumulation une accumulation de
mesures alors nous on a une position qui
est sur la sécurité ne pas s'enfoncer
dans le tout sécuritaire
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron n'a pas
remis de police de proximité n'a pas
redonné des moyens notamment dans les
commissariats qui sont dégradées n'a pas
remis ce lien et cette confiance qui
doit être établie entre la police et les
populations donc derrière les grandes
annonces des manuels mc ren on voit
qu'il ya du vent et que les manuels
macro on parle de sécurité je rappelle
quand même une chose c'est que c'est lui
qui a mis en place une nouvelle
stratégie du maintien de l'ordre qui
s'est traduit par d'innombrables blessés
y compris des gens qui ont été tuées
lors des manifestations
donc on n'a pas de leçon à recevoir sur
la question de la sécurité de la part de
ceux présents jean didier berthault sur
les retraites parce qu'on sent c'était
particulièrement voilà une campagne en
tout cas pour pour l' après 2022
on pourra travailler plus la fin des
régimes spéciaux ça aussi ça se
rapproche de la droite vous étiez plutôt
satisfait avec cette approche
il revient il revient aujourd'hui à un
débat sur les retraites qu'on a déjà eu
il ya cinq ans qui était acté que la
droite d'ailleurs avait engagé à
plusieurs reprises sous d'autres
quinquennat il n'a pas avancé pourquoi
parce que la situation sociale est
extrêmement compliqué et qu'il a
lui-même créé cette situation sociale
conflictuelle alors aujourd'hui alors
oui d'accord lors fall et gilet jaune
c'était quand même pas le coc vide un
bon c'était une situation qu'il a
lui-même créé aujourd'hui revient avec
le chéquier
ouvert pour distribuer les primes à
droite à gauche et puis ensuite les
appliquer avec les idées des autres
honnêtement je pense pas que le courage
qu'il n'a pas eu pour appliquer cette
réforme des retraites pendant les trois
dernières années des cinq dernières
années il aura dans les cinq prochaines
thomas porte sur cette question des
retraites
génération est évidemment puisqu'il
parle de la réforme des retraites il dit
qu'il ne va pas le mettre en place mais
il dit qu'il faudra allonger la durée de
cotisation il dit qui la mettra en place
sûrement plus tard nous on l'a toujours
dit on est opposé à cette réforme là des
retraites qui est absolument scandaleuse
qui va amener une augmentation du temps
de travail qui va baisser y compris les
pensions à la fin puisque on sortira
d'un système de solidarité tel qu'on le
connaît aujourd'hui qui n'est pas
parfait et qu'il faudra retravailler
pour qu'ils soient financés et permettre
à chacune et chacun d'avoir une retraite
décente mais en vérité on a un peu aussi
l'impression qu'ils emmanuel macron en
jambes l'élection présidentielle et qui
nous parle comme s'il était déjà élu et
je crois que les jeux ne sera absolument
pas fait
jean didier berthault pour terminer sur
cette question d'origine du débat ce qu
il fait campagne par la droite devant
une france du traitement qui se droitise
en tout cas dans les études d'opinion
qui sont quand même majoritairement qui
donne la part belle à la droite
française c'est ce qu'ils avaient le
choix emmanuel macron il serait
suicidaire d'aller sur sa gauche mais
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il surtout il ne
sait plus où il va voilà donc on à
arsène macro emmanuel lupin on sait pas
il appliquer le chéquier pour le
chéquier de la france pour deux tribus
et des chèques à tire larigot depuis
quelques semaines aujourd'hui il vient
piquer les idées des candidats
républicains il est paumé c'est un
président aujourd'hui qui est paumé et
un président qui est beau mais c'est
clairement quelqu'un à qui on ne peut
pas faire confiance pour l'avenir alors
autre question j'aimerais aborder avec
vous on en a peu parlé aujourd'hui dans
les médias mais c'est une petite phrase
concernant cette fois-ci la diplomatie
et la géopolitique que président a
prononcé hier écouter mais la france ne
sera pas forte seuls les enjeux sont
tels dans le choc des puissances
continentales qui se déploie sous nos
yeux que seule une entente européenne
solidaire et volontaire peut apporter à
chacun de nos pays européens un relais
et une force de frappe il suffit
d'ouvrir les yeux pour mesurer combien
nos intérêts se rencontrer s'accordent
c'est dans ce contexte du choc des
puissances américaines chinoises russes
et de déstabilisation de nombreuses
zones du monde que notre pays aura dans
deux mois la charge de présider l'union
européenne avec la chine la russie et
les etats unis dans la même phrase c'est
pas courant dans la bouche du président
de la république la crise des sous
marins australiens portée j'allais
j'avais vous le dire
son allocution sur la partie
internationale c'est franchement la plus
ridicule la france n'a jamais été autant
affaibli sur la scène internationale et
ça me fait mal de le dire parce que
c'est notre pays mais on l'a vu avec la
crise des sous marins on l'a vu avec
l'humiliation américaine derrière on a
vu avec la crise de la pêche avec le
royaume-uni donc venir nous parler
aujourd'hui de la place de la france en
europe c'est bien on comprend bien aussi
qu'ils préparent la présidence française
de l'union européenne pendant la
campagne présidentielle ça n'a échappé à
personne mais clairement le bilan sur la
scène internationale il est aussi
désastreux et la france est affaiblie et
encore une fois je ne m'en contente pas
voilà c'est triste pour notre pays
thomas porte mais ne mettront justement
le sauveur à la tête de l'europe bientôt
il va pouvoir encore peut-être faire
campagne dans ce cadre-là contre les
ennemis des stabilisateurs ça vous
évoque quoi c'est c'est habile pour vous
la part d'un président en campagne non
je crois que c'est la politique des
petites phrases emmanuel macron nous a
habitué à ça depuis des années
d'ailleurs ces petites phrases là qui
distille qui alimente souvent les
tensions qui sont faits au travers de
déclarations de presse et qui crée après
entre plusieurs pays des tensions mais
emmanuel macron il prépare la présence
de la france à l'union européenne ce qui
est aussi un problème démocratique
puisqu'il va être candidat à l'élection
présidentielle il va être président de
l'europe donc tout ça se mélange alors
qu'on ne sait pas s'il va être réélu ce
que ça va donner après donc je crois que
c'est pas sérieux d'être aujourd'hui
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
d'être président de mélanger aussi la
présence de l'europe donc tout ça fait
un enchevêtrement de mandats qu'ils
donnent à voir que finalement peut-être
que sa préoccupation principale c'est
pas celle des françaises et des français
c'est extrêmement dommage dans la
période que l'on traverse alors pour
terminer justement je me tombe
particulièrement vers vous un porte
parole de xavier bertrand qui peine
depuis le début de sa campagne pour une
autre politique étrangère je vous
propose d'écouter votre couleur sur rtl
c'était le 19 février dernier
nous devons mettre fin à cette guerre
froide avec la russie il est urgent de
renouer un dialogue politique avec le
président russe mais aussi avec le
président chinois à ça il a fait fausse
route aussi dans son cv gars là aussi
veut dire qu'il est important que la
france reprenne les rênes de son destin
voilà c'est à dire que à un moment donné
on ne peut pas simplement se fâcher avec
des pays parce que les américains ont
décidé la france a des amis elle a des
alliés mais elle a aussi son
indépendance elle a aussi sa politique
étrangère et elle doit être souveraine
dans sa politique étrangère c'est tout
le sens des propos de xavier bertrand
merci en tout cas à tous les deux
liberto merci également à vous auto
m'apporte d'avoir été avec nous pour ce
décryptage ce soir
emmanuel macron qui s'est aussi adressé
à la jeunesse un vantant son bilan hier
notamment pour les jeunes les plus
défavorisés
concernant justement ce thème a mis en
avant par emmanuel macron nous nous
sommes posé la question que dit la
réalité de terrain quel est le quotidien
de ces jeunes frappés de plein fouet par
la crise post- qu'ovide notre rubrique
qu'en pensent les français nous sommes
allés ce soir la rencontre d'isadora qui
a du mal à joindre les deux bouts
reportage signé celle farge et robin
dubois
je suis dans le xviie arrondissement de
paris je vais rencontrer isadora elle
est étudiante en deuxième année de
licence d'histoire-géographie l'année
2020 l'année qu'au vite comme on
l'appelle a parfois été éprouvante pour
les étudiants et vous allez voir que
l'année 2000 21 l'est tout autant
bonjour isadora bonjour installe merci
beaucoup de répondre à nos questions
alors vous avez est étudiante en
histoire géo qu'est ce que c'est d'être
étudiant en france aujourd'hui en 2021
et bien c'est tout à fait particulier je
pense que c'est assez même extrême dans
l'histoire étant donné que c'est très
difficile et on essaie de s'en sortir
comme on peut et de réussir nos études
alors justement donc là on sort d'une
année compliquée 2020 c'était quelques
vite c'est le continent vous vous étiez
en première année comment est ce que
vous avez vécu cette année ça a été donc
au monde tout à fait particulier que je
découvrais c'est à dire le monde
universitaire je sortais du secondaire
avec un bac qu'ovide donc c'est à dire
un bac en contrôle continu
et une mise en confinement dès février
mars avec
et une communication sur les aide pas
assez divulgué donc j'ai dû vraiment
beaucoup cherché
il y en a eu quand même certaines merci
à eux merci à la solidarité étudiante
qu'est ce que vous avez ressenti pendant
cette année qui a été particulière à un
abandon total du gouvernement j'ai
ressenti un abandon total du
gouvernement ça c'est indubitable c'est
clairement
nous laisser nous débrouiller dans un
marché professionnel qui a été
complètement les et qui a été
complètement
mis sous cloche à cause du code idée on
comprend pourquoi évidemment mais
derrière de n'avoir aucun parachute
vis-à-vis de cette fin crise énorme
économique qui a secoué tout le monde
entier j'ai la chance d'avoir au moins
une bourse c'est à dire
570 euros par mois avec 170 euros plus
des appels est ce que vous arrivez
aujourd'hui à
à boucler vos fins de mois à payer votre
loyer
tout juste oui ton juste oui oui tout
juste d'une quête du système d à bas le
système de bien sûr je vous montrerai
les astuces vous nous montrez bien sûr
qu'il adorait ont parlé des 18 system
des étudiants comment vous par exemple
est ce que vous vous débrouillez pour
vous alimenter correctement
alors pour je sais que pour
l'alimentation pour tous qui est sorti
pour tout ce qui est des dépenses en
dehors des frais fixes que j'ai à payer
j'ai 240 euros
240 euros vraiment pour tout faire
c'est 1 240 euros pour tout faire quand
on veut quand on est jeune qu'on veut
sortir un petit peu quand on veut se
nourrir c'est quoi c'est le parcours du
combattant
absolument absolument c'est trouver des
stratagèmes au quotidien pour payer moi
mais autre plan b en plus donc j'ai jeu
à travers facebook ou les réseaux
sociaux ou même dehors quand je me
balade
repère rapidement des bouquins qui est
qui qui traînent dans les bouquins
concon voilà
ça c'est des bouquins que vous avez
voilà c'est ça que j'ai enfin trouvé
soit dehors soit des bouquins vraiment
de facebook vraiment de tout et
n'importe quoi
vraiment qui permettent ensuite à d'être
revendus et de d'avoir un petit
complément de revenu
c'est pas grand chose mais c'est quand
même là ça c'est des petits revenus dont
vous pouvez pas vous passer aujourd'hui
c'est toujours du plus oui c'est
toujours du plus qui permet de temps en
temps un peu sortir quand même de faire
comme les autres de aller dans un bar à
paris toute la vie vraiment énorme
d'ailleurs je me demande pourquoi
justement pour les étudiants pour les
revenus les bourses donc pourquoi enfin
une idée aurait été de d'infléchir sa
sur le coût de la vie en fonction de
l'espace géographique qu'occupe
l'étudiant vous êtes en 2e année
aujourd'hui est ce que vous aviez c'est
ce que vous aviez imaginé la vie
étudiante est ce que vous étiez au lycée
je m'imaginais vraiment quelque chose de
ou tout allait être simple tout allait
être resplendissante avec beaucoup
d'échangés intellectuels où on allait
pouvoir se rencontrer entre les
disciplines pouvoir échanger créer des
utopies et au final on se retrouve
depuis notre studio d'étudiant pour ceux
qui ont la chance d'avoir un studio a eu
effectivement je m'attendais pas à faire
en face à face permanent avec mon
ordinateur pour l'avenir et ce que
globalement vous dit vous vous dites
plutôt confiante en l'avenir ou plutôt
méfiant de corisco comment est-ce que
vous abordez les choses aujourd'hui je
suis tout à fait très inquiète très
inquiète avec un diplôme universitaire
remontant du coc vide je suis persuadé
que des employeurs sur la marché de
l'emploi quand ils verront deux jeunes
avec un
une licence non période de vide et une
période qu'ovide forcément préféré
l'étudiant n'ont pas l'air trop vite car
il saura qu'il a été formé bon aux
minima correctement nous on a les
programmes ont été raccourcies donc
énormément de cours ont été mis à
distance des professeurs qui arrive pas
avec forcément à l'informatique à se
débrouiller ou quoi des polycopiés bah
non c'est comme ça
dc c'est ça aujourd'hui les études et
c'est vraiment un des avantages énormes
qu'on a
dans l'actualité en france également
aujourd'hui quarante deuxième jour du
procès des attaques du 13 novembre 2015
à la barre cet après midi un témoin pas
comme les autres françois hollande le
président de la république à l'époque
des faits entendu comme témoin depuis le
début des audiences le principal accusé
s'adapter cela va justifier les attaques
djihadistes en riposte à la politique
étrangère de la france et de son chef de
l'état d'alors ont fait le point avec
notre reporter katia pique nique à la
cour d'assises spéciale de paris
françois hollande a expliqué qu'il était
présent aujourd'hui pour témoigner de ce
que fut son rôle durant cette nuit
funeste et témoigner de ses décisions
dans les mois précédents l'ancien
président français expliqué qu'il devait
aux victimes des explications le
terrorisme n'ont pas attaqué notre mode
d'action à l'étranger mais notre mode de
vie c'est exactement le contraire qui
avait prétendu salle abdeslam lorsqu'il
avait blâmé les frappes de la france
françois hollande cet argument n'est
qu'une attaque politique de neige dans
leur appétit de conquête il a expliqué
que le kurdistan et autres acteurs
politiques d'irak avait fait appel à la
france en août 2014 dans le cadre de la
coalition en ce qui concerne la syrie
françois hollande a expliqué qu'il n'a
organisé des frappes que fin septembre
2015 uniquement pour réagir à
l'existence de camps d'entraînement de
terroristes qui complotait contre la
france on n'a pas frappé de civils at il
assuré tout en reconnaissant que les
jihadistes cachés parfois dans des
immeubles de civils et que la france
visait déjà à des lamidat bas ou d'un
des organisateurs des attentats depuis
juillet 2015 mais qu'il n'avait pas
réussi à le neutraliser l'existence
d'une liste de djihadiste français que
les services secrets syriens voulait
transmettre refusé par valls je cite
françois hollande on ne collabore pas
avec le régime de bachar al assad ses
explications étaient attendus par les
parties civiles et par arthur des
nouveaux le président de l'association
life for paris ce qui l'a cité en tant
que témoin on les écoute bah je pense
que françois hollande nous a permis de
mieux comprendre quel était le degré de
connaissance de l'état sur les projets
de l'état islamique à l'époque sur ce
qui avait pu être mis en oeuvre il a
aussi fait la lumière en partie sur les
opérations de police ce soir là en
disant qu'il avait donné son accord de
principe
dès son arrivée à la cellule place
beauvau et tous ces éléments là en fait
n'apparaissait pas encore au dossier
n'était jamais apparu dans des
interviews donc on a appris des choses
et c'était ça le sens de le faire venir
aujourd'hui avoir déjà on a appris qu'en
fait ils n'étaient pas visés au stade de
france parce que même lui n'a décidé
qu'à la dernière minute d'y aller et ça
c'était une info par exemple qu'on
n'allait pas on pouvait penser qu'il
était visé et donc ça c'est très
important et on a appris ça ensuite ce
qui était important c'était d'avoir le
chef de l'état c'était d'avoir quelqu'un
qui représente la société française à
l'époque des faits venaient à dire ce
qu'ils savaient venir aussi dire sa
compassion à l'égard des victimes ça
fait partie des choses que nous on a
besoin d'entendre et qu'on a pu entendre
aujourd'hui donc c'était important
françois hollande a été claire mais il a
éludé certains points embarrassant en
tout cas et les formelle à la question
pouvait-on éviter ce drame il répond
n'avions pas hélas l'information pour
empêcher les attentats du 13 novembre il
savait qu'il existait une menace mais
pas de détails sur ces auteurs ni sur la
date
l'actualité internationale marquée par
la crise des migrants la frontière entre
la biélorussie et la pologne où des
milliers d'entre sont massés dans un
froid glacial
varsovie accuse minsk d'orchestrer cette
crise migratoire selon la pologne la
biélorussie veut faire pression sur
l'union européenne pour éviter une
nouvelle salve de sanctions en attendant
une sortie crise des conditions de vie
des réfugiés sur place sont de plus en
plus difficile notre envoyé spécial en
train de clairon se trouve au coeur de
ce campement de fortune
nous avons maintenant à faire un camp
qui se structure de plus en plus les
tentes des premiers jours laissent peu à
peu place à des cabanes plus élaborée en
effet ce n'est pas la matière première
qui manque les allers-retours sont
incessants entre la forêt d'une part on
trouve boulot et sapins et ce campement
de fortune d'autre part la situation
sanitaire elle reste très près car les
fils yannick mans quelques points d'eau
d'installer des citernes installées le
long de ce campement de fortune nous
avons pu parcourir ce camp en long et en
large et nous avons rencontré à
plusieurs reprises des gens à l'état de
santé fragile fragilisé justement parlé
de nuit qu'ils viennent de passer les
deux nuits où les températures étaient
négatives vous propose d'écouter à ce
sujet le témoignage d'un migrant irak
si vous nous laisser franchir la
frontière aujourd'hui nous chanterons
votre hymne national pour toujours votre
drapeau sera toujours accroché dans nos
maisons is
god
cada et s'il vous plaît
regardez cette preuve quand vous êtes
venus chez nous quand le peuple polonais
est venu chez nous de l'iran nous
n'avons pas fermé la frontière nous
avons dit venez s'il vous plaît
bienvenue et maintenant pourquoi vous
nous traitez comme ça
monsieur le président polonais
regardez ça s'il vous plaît ne voyez
vous pas les enfants peuvent mourir il
fait très froid
nous ne survivrons pas encore deux jours
cette femme est enceinte de huit mois
elle a aussi des enfants et la situation
risque de se tendre encore davantage
avec l'arrivée aujourd'hui de plusieurs
centaines de nouveaux migrants nous
avons donc un camp qui grossit main
quand je le disais qui se structure et
cela montre bien une chose les gens ici
sont déterminées à rester coûte que
coûte jusqu'à ce qu'une solution leur
soit trouvée pour leur passage de
l'autre côté de la frontière et cette
crise migratoire est intolérable pour
les nations unies le conseil de sécurité
de l'onu convoque d'ailleurs une réunion
d'urgence demain l'inquiétude grandit
dans le monde et les relations
diplomatiques dans la région ne cesse de
se dégrader robin pu l
la tension diplomatique ne retombe pas
entre la pologne et la biélorussie
ce mercredi le premier ministre polonais
a dénoncé en terrorisme d'état de la
part de son voisin d accusation
contestée par la diplomatie biélorusse
soutenue par la russie moscou à
d'ailleurs tenu à rappeler le contexte
de cette crise migratoire
nous avons également déclaré à plusieurs
reprises qu'on ne pouvait pas rejeter
sur minsk la responsabilité de la
nouvelle escalade de la crise migratoire
en europe
car ce n'est pas en novembre 2000 21 ou
à l'été 2000 21 ou au printemps 2021
qu'elle a commencé
elle est dans une phase active depuis
plusieurs années déjà cette crise
migratoire cet exode de personnes des
pays dans lesquels les soi disant
démocratie développée on décide
d'établir leur propre ordre chez les
nordistes souhaitent pas l'être la
pologne à l'union européenne accuse le
président biélorusse alexandre
loukachenko
d'alimenter les tensions délivrant des
visas à des migrants et en les
acheminant à la frontière une situation
humanitaire dénoncée par les
responsables européens qui réclame des
sanctions on utilise des êtres humains
des hommes des femmes des enfants on as
a une frontière on menace pour faire
pression sur l'union européenne parce
qu'il ya eu des sanctions qui ont été
prises du fait d'une répression et de
l'arrestation d'opposants à la suite de
la réélection très controversé du
président lukashenko c'est ça il faut se
figurer ce que c'est évidemment ça
appelle toute condamnation faisons face
à cette attaque hybride brutale violente
et indigne la seule réponse est à la
fois la fermeté est à la fois l'unité
mettait aussi la promotion de nos
valeurs fondamentales une réunion des
ministres des affaires étrangères de
l'ue eux doit se tenir lundi pour
établir une stratégie commune face à la
crise des migrants à la frontière entre
la pologne et la biélorussie et une
crise migratoire au cas d'une rencontre
en russie le ministre russe des affaires
étrangères et son homologue biélorusse
ont tenu une conférence de presse
commune ce matin à moscou les précisions
avec notre correspondante en russie
verra goffman
envoyé des milliers de militaires face à
des femmes et des enfants réfugiés est
une violation de toutes les normes
imaginables a déclaré le ministre des
affaires étrangères de la biais là aussi
vladimir mcee lors d'une conférence de
presse conjointe ce mercredi avec son
homologue russe sergueï lavrov
la dmr mac est également pointé du doigt
l'hypocrisie de l'union européenne qui
acceptent les migrants qui arrivent sur
son sol via la méditerranée où les
balkans mais emploie la force contre ce
qui transite par la biélorussie écoutez
cette politique sans cerveau d'un nombre
de dirigeants des pays occidentaux est
devenue la norme aujourd'hui il n'essaye
même pas de compte et la situation
ne voit pas dans l'avenir la plus proche
et l'ignorent les choses principal
moteur en faisant sortir 2000
quinze mille déjà un militaire
contre les migrants un contre les femmes
et les enfants qui pleurent et ne pas ne
les laissant pas entrer en europe où ils
cherchent tellement à venir pour moi
c'est une situation impossible à
imaginer c'est la violation de toutes
les normes imaginables et en plus ils
nous accusent d'organiser ces flux mais
ça n'a rien à voir avec les riders
pourquoi il y a des balkans il ya la
méditerranée il y à des migrants qui
reçoivent
des privilèges et une protection donc
les migrants qui provient qui viennent
de ces décès et de ces endroits qui
l'habille lui si c'est ça pose problème
quant au chef de la diplomatie russe
sergueï lavrov et l'a évoqué le rôle de
la russie dans la crise migratoire
répondant ainsi au premier ministre
polonais qui accusait vladimir poutine
d'être coresponsables de cette situation
qualifiée par varsovie d'attac hybride
écoutez nous n'avons pas reçu de
demandes ni des polos n'a dit ni des
lituaniens à propos de d'un éventuel
rôle de médiation dans cette discussion
je pense qu'ils n'ont rien demandé mais
il simplement imposer leur
importance en faisant des déclarations
de ce type accusant la biélorussie et du
même coup la russie d'être à l'origine
de ces événements et je considère que
c'est une nouvelle fois une
manifestation de ce que nous venons dire
c'est à dire une manifestation de ce
complexe de supériorité du complexe de
grandeur
d'impunité dans toutes les questions
plusieurs milliers de migrants
principalement originaires du
moyen-orient est arrivé avec un visa
biélorusse pour rejoindre l'union
européenne se trouve depuis maintenant
trois jours face à une frontière
polonaise hérissée de barbelés et gardé
par des milliers de militaires polonais
et pour aller plus loin on reçoit tout
de suite sur ce plateau claude gans
maison expert en relations
internationales bonsoir co2
blanchemaison des fois on voit que dans
ce dossier les interprétations divergent
comme souvent notamment les accusés eux
les européens qui accusent pardon depuis
des mois le président biélorusse de
nourrir la crise en délivrant des visas
on l'a entendu à des migrants pour se
venger des sanctions européennes vous y
voyez une sorte de vengeance est ce
qu'on a les preuves de ce qu'on avance
en tout cas du côté européen dans les
relations entre états il n'y a pas
vraiment de vengeance il ya des rapports
de force et en effet monsieur
loukachenko pense probablement qu'il
peut faire pression sur la pologne sur
la lituanie sur la lettonie et par
conséquent sur l'union européenne avec
cet afflux de migrants qui viennent
beaucoup de beurre pour la plupart de
syrie ou ou qui sont des purs deux
irakiens et
effectivement la pologne se défend en
fermant la frontière et ça lui permet de
se poser d'ailleurs en gardienne de la
frontière européenne ce qui en
l'occurrence davantage alors je crois
que chacun joue son rôle dans cette
affaire monsieur loukachenko qui est
quand même gêné par les sanctions
européennes qui surtout vrai éviter
qu'ils en aient une nouvelle couche en
quelques jours ce qui est probable
compte tenu des éléments factuels parce
qu'il a quand même beaucoup d'éléments
factuels je pense que la chancelière
allemande
alors ce qu'elle a appelé le président
russe a dû lui dire bon moi j'ai une
certaine expérience de ce genre de sujet
il ya cinq ans lorsque les millions
d'ici rien arrivé aucun le passé par
minsk alors pourquoi aujourd'hui passent
tous par mille c'est quand même bizarre
donc effectivement
100 ans en sang sans poser qui viennent
responsabilité russe dans cette affaire
il est clair que l a probablement
demandé au président russe qui
n'interviennent auprès de monsieur
loukachenko pour qu'ils se montrent plus
plus accommodant dans cette affaire et
qui ne cherche pas l'affrontement avec
l'union européenne d'autant plus qu'ils
risquent de le perdre justement à un
gala merkel qui demandent si j'ai bien
compris en tout cas les termes en aigle
accès d'user de son influence un
vladimir poutine est ce qu'il est
vraiment une marge de manoeuvre élevé
non dans cette affaire il peut vous
conseiller à monsieur loukachenko d'être
plus modérée dans cette affaire
effectivement il peut aussi lui dire que
dans le fond personne ne sait comment
c'est les affaires tourneront plus tard
mais certains disent que monsieur
loukachenko utilisent ces réfugiés comme
dans le fond une une masse de manoeuvre
et qu'il en fait dans le fond d c'est
une sorte de te traite des réfugiés qui
ça qui ce qui peut être assimilé à la
traite des êtres humains par conséquent
ça c est un crime contre l'humanité et
peut-être que certains tribunaux
internationaux pourraient un jour
demander des comptes à monsieur
loukachenko donc ça aussi c'est quelque
chose qui peut être efficace d'autant
plus que monsieur le catch est co devra
bien
revenir un jour et parler à l'union
européenne alors venir poutine qui
renvoie en tout cas des discussions
directes entre lure et minsk et qui dit
un peu taquin quand même que les
occidentaux devrait plutôt s'occuper des
flux de migrants provoqué par leurs
interventions au moyen-orient c'est de
bonne guerre oui c'est logique qu'ils
disent il faudrait que l'union
européenne discutent directement avec
monsieur loukachenko non mais se sont
entendus il ya une part de
responsabilité aussi de la part des
occidentaux alors
d'abord qu'elle discute avec une
européenne puisque l'union européenne
mais les sanctions sur le cas de chaque
côté qu'elle ne reconnaît pas son
élection donc la meilleure façon de
reconnaître l'élection ce serait
effectivement d'entamer des négociations
pour essayer de trouver un accord ce que
l'union européenne n'est pas prête à
faire dans l'état actuel des choses si
rien ne se produit alors est ce que
l'union européenne a une responsabilité
dans la situation actuelle
la responsabilité c'est d'abord la
guerre en syrie bien entendu qu'il y a
cinq ans à déplacer des millions de
personnes la turquie en a accueilli à
peu près 3 millions et demi ce qui est
beaucoup et puis d'autres sont venus un
million sont venus en allemagne et ce
qui est frappant c'est que tous les gens
qui partent vers minsk ne souhaite pas
rester en biélorussie la russie la
biélorussie n'est pas considéré comme
une terre d'accueil est d'ailleurs
monsieur loukachenko ne souhaite pas les
garder sur son territoire par conséquent
cette pompe aspirante de réfugiés
refoulante vers des états de l'union
européenne c'est un peu bizarre pourquoi
est-ce que ça a été organisé est-ce que
ça a des chances de réussir ça n'est pas
sûr et comment en sortir puisque comme
vous dis qu'ils n'ont pas nécessairement
envie de rester à minsk qui veulent
aller voir l'europe ne veut pas les les
accueillir notamment en raison aussi des
opinions publiques en effet la
circulation la situation humanitaire de
ces réfugiés est catastrophique qu'il y
à des familles entières avec des femmes
des enfants c'est une région
naturellement l'hiver et précoce tour
qui fait très fort il fait très froid
des gens vont mourir ils ont des
problèmes de santé ils ont des problèmes
alimentaires eh bien il ya des agences
de l'onu qui sont spécialisés pour cela
et en effet il serait probablement utile
que les agences de l'onu spécialisée
pour cela intervienne pour avoir accès à
ces réfugiés le ministre de l'intérieur
allemand qui est cs ou par conséquent un
bon conservateur de bavière a d'ailleurs
proposé que
des couloirs humanitaires soit établi
pour que les humanitaires puissent
accéder à s'y réfugier là où ils sont
c'est à dire actuellement en biélorussie
pour les soigner et les alimenter
complication supplémentaire
la france fait partie des pays 1 ce soir
qui ont demandé une réunion d'urgence au
conseil de sécurité de l'onu qu'est ce
qu'on peut en attendre précisément il
est probable que il n'y aura pas de
consensus entre entre les pays les
membres permanents du conseil de
sécurité pour faire intervenir les
agences de l'onu mais je crois que c'est
utile que le conseil se saisisse de
cette affaire pour établir les
responsabilités et il ya probablement
des responsabilités du côté du côté de
minsk mais il y en a aussi ailleurs
parce que on a établi maintenant qu'il
existe au liban en irak en syrie en
turquie des officines qui propose un
package avec un vol direct pour minsk et
un visa pour la biélorussie moyenne ont
naturellement le paiement de quelques
milliers de dollars et ça s'est
substituée aux pacers classique aux
passeurs qui faisait venir les réfugiés
il ya cinq ans par la voie directe par
les balkans en allemagne et dans
d'autres pays et donc je pense que
inévitablement inévitablement l'union
européenne va prendre des sanctions
contre les compagnies aériennes qui se
prêtent à ce trafic et parmi ces
compagnies aériennes il ya évidemment la
compagnie biélorusse bien loin via et
puis turkish airlines qui apparemment
puisque on le sait tout le monde voit
les avions partir tout le monde voit les
avions arrivé et tout le monde connaît
aussi les officines qui délivre c'est
package visas et billets de voyage et
par conséquent je pense que des
sanctions seront prises contre ces gens
qui participent à ce transfert de
population sans espoir à vrai dire parce
que pourquoi la pologne voudrait-elle
ses frontières la pologne d'ailleurs
joue son jeu ça lui permet de faire
diversion par rapport à la mauvaise
presse qu'elle a à bruxelles évidemment
puisque elle respecte plus l'état de
droit et ça lui permet d'apparaître
comme le défenseur ou aux avant-postes
de la frontière de venir peine alors
qu'elle refuse l'intervention de frontex
l'intervention d'europol et toutes les
interventions des agences européennes
qui pourraient aider à résoudre le
problème donc la pologne ne fait pas
preuve de volonté européenne elle
simplement elle fait preuve d'une
volonté politique de stigmatiser cette
affût cet afflux est peut-être d'en
rendre la russie complices c'est donc
dans les deux cas une instrumentation
des réfugiés par par le gouvernement de
minsk et par le gouvernement polonais
merci beaucoup en tout cas clos de
blanchemaison de ce décryptage
et dans le reste de l'ue dans le reste
de l'actualité internationale ce bras de
fer qui oppose l'ethiopie et la
communauté internationale addis abeba
retient plus de 70 chauffeur du
programme alimentaire mondial selon les
nations unies le secrétaire d'état
américain anthony blinken estime ce soir
qu'il n'existe une fenêtre il existe une
fenêtre pour stopper la guerre en toile
de fond le conflit dans la région du
tigré et le difficile acheminement de
l'aide humanitaire adrien photo avec
bilal boiseau
c'est une nouvelle alerte venue des
nations unies et elle ne devrait pas
rassurer sur le sort de l'ethiopie non
il campe le direct personne ne peut
prédire ce que la poursuite des combats
et l'insécurité entraîneront mais soyons
clairs ce qui est certain c'est que le
risque que l'ethiopie sombre dans une
guerre civile de plus en plus étendues
n'est que trop réelle les répercussions
politiques d'une intensification de la
violence dans la région serait immense
et viendrait s'ajouter aux nombreuses
crise qui secoue la corne de l'afrique
la violence en ethiopie est aussi
psychologique pour les habitants alors
que les troupes rebelles se renforce le
gouvernement fédéral impose depuis
plusieurs mois un blocus économique
l'onu a affirmé que 72 chauffeur du
programme alimentaire mondial était
retenu dans le pays moins de nourriture
mais aussi de mai dicaments ou encore de
carburant pour freiner le front de
libération du peuple du tigré des
décisions qui impacte également la
population mais selon certains
protagonistes la sécurité du pays
justifie tous les sacrifices pendant
la guerre a endommagé l'économie mais
avec la foi en dieu les choses vont
s'améliorer c'est ce que nous espérons
oui nous perdons de l'argent mais même
si nous devons sacrifier nos vies nous
sommes prêts à le faire pour sauver
notre pays nous sommes prêts n'avons pas
le choix il faut un pays pour pouvoir
vivre une fois la paix pour que les gens
puissent vivre et cela doit nous coûter
la vie pour que la prochaine génération
puisse avoir une vie meilleure qu'il en
soit ainsi
entre la progression du mouvement
rebelle et les frappes aériennes menées
par l'armée éthiopienne des milliers de
morts sont à déplorer depuis plus d'un
an et il n'y suis favorable au conflit
semble toujours plus incertaine
tous les dirigeants ici addis abeba et
dans le nord qu'on vienne
individuellement que les différences
entre eux sont politiques et nécessitent
des solutions politiques par le dialogue
sommes-nous ce
dialogue
cela constitue donc une opportunité que
nous pouvons exploiter collectivement
pour aider le peuple éthiopien à trouver
une solution durable à la crise actuelle
pour l'auteur
offense aux missions il est toutefois
important de mentionner que la fenêtre
dont nous disposons est très petit et
que le temps écouter balles et les taux
en vain du time in short la semaine
passée le porte parole du tplf affirmé
qu aucun bain de sang ne seraient commis
en cas d'entrée des forces rebelles dans
la capitale un discours loin du rapport
rendu par l'onu sur les possibles crimes
de guerre commis dans le pays
en afrique a toujours l'air ouverture
d'une décharge en tunisie a provoqué
hier de heurts entre manifestants et
forces de l'ordre une puissante
plateforme syndicale appelle à une grève
générale pour forcer les autorités à
prendre responsabilité le point à tunis
avec notre correspondant bassem chez lui
c'est une crise des déchets qui a viré à
l'affrontement à grève dans le
gouvernorat de sfax depuis plusieurs
mois riverains et associations n'ont
cessé d'alerter les autorités locales
quant aux dangers générés par cette
décharge à ciel ouvert
véritable scandale écologique et
sanitaire sous la pression de la
population des responsables de la
décharge ont décidé fin septembre de sa
fermeture générant ainsi des tensions
avec les municipalités de la région qui
en réponse ont décidé de suspendre la
collecte des ordures ces dernières
semaines des mouvements de protestations
se sont multipliées contre les déchets
envahissant les rues et les trottoirs et
menaçant la santé des habitants hier des
heurts ont éclaté entre forces de
l'ordre et riverains en colère causant
la mort d'un jeune homme de 35 ans
asphyxié selon les manifestants et sa
famille par des gaz lacrymogènes
utilisés pour disperser la foule alors
que le parquet de sfax a ouvert une
enquête pour déterminer les causes
exactes de ce décès le porte parole du
ministère de l'intérieur a démenti dans
un communiqué la responsabilité des
forces de l'ordre dans ce drame l'homme
a eu un problème de santé loin des
protestations son hospitalisation et sa
mort n'ont rien à voir avec ce qui s'est
passé il est décédé suite à un malaise
survenu à son domicile situé à 6
kilomètres du lieu des manifestations
l'un de ses proches l'a conduit à
l'hôpital de la région où il est décédé
alors qu'un poste de la garde nationale
a été incendié par les manifestants
la chef du gouvernement n'a jamais boudé
le ministre de l'intérieur taoufik
charfeddine ont souligné l'urgence de
résoudre rapidement le problème des
déchets à sfax la puissante centrale
syndicale ugtt et et a appelé à une
grève générale contre les violences
policières et l'inaction du gouvernement
dans ce dossier écoutez nous appelons à
une grève générale dans les secteurs
public et privé à agareb et exigeons la
levée du blocus sécuritaire imposé à la
ville d'agde hareb et l'activation de
l'accord sur la fermeture définitive de
la déchetterie chaque année en tunisie
ce sont près de 2 5 millions de tonnes
de déchets qui sont enfouis dans des
décharges à ciel ouvert sans traitement
ni incinération
un petit détour au chili à présent où
les députés approuvent la procédure de
destitution lancé contre le président
sebastian pinera en cause la vente
controversée d'une compagnie minière
réalisé dans un paradis fiscal une
affaire révélée par l' enquête
internationale des pandora papers
françois this kiewit ch si les crocos la
yale preuves et il éprouvera 15 heures
c'est le temps passé par le député
socialiste ray ménard hangzhou à lire un
texte de 1300 pages dans lequel il
appelle à en finir avec l'impunité
[Applaudissements]
avec 78 voix pour et 67 contre les
députés chiliens ont donné leur accord à
une procédure de destitution du
président sebastian pinera
est possible il est possible que demain
nous ayons un président qu'il soit un
exemple pour le reste des chiliens et
non plus la situation dans laquelle nous
nous trouvons aujourd'hui où nous avons
un président qui a non seulement agi en
dehors de la probité administrative
requises dans la fonction qu'il occupe
mais qui a aussi gravement porté
atteinte à l'image de la nation
leur colère est surtout liée à la vente
par sebastian pinera d'un vaste projet
minier réalisée via un paradis fiscal
est révélée par l' enquête
internationale dite des pandora paper un
projet controversé car située dans la
région de coquimbo à seulement une
trentaine de kilomètres de la réserve
nationale du manchot de humboldt une
espèce protégée
[Musique]
mais en 2010 le président et homme
d'affaires vend sa part dans le projet
un de ses amis proches une vente pour un
montant de 152 millions de dollars dont
la majeure partie de l'opération a été
réalisée dans les îles vierges
britanniques parmi les conditions de
paiement la déclaration de cette zone en
réserve naturelle mais le gouvernement
de pin ira n'a pas fait cette
déclaration
accusé par l'opposition d'avoir violé la
constitution
sebastian pinera dément tout conflit
d'intérêts et clame sa totale innocence
il explique qu'en 2017 une enquête
approfondie du ministère public avait
conclu à un non-lieu
la récession dès la méditation la
décision de la direction de ces sociétés
de vendredi nairas de minga en 2010 pour
laquelle je n'ai été ni consultés ni
informés visait précisément éviter tout
soupçon de conflit d'intérêt et ne pas
le faire aurait pu conduire à un bon
fille d'un terreau est pris à l origine
à albon correct aux intérêts mais pas
les sapes janota mentana septembre je
considère qu'il est absolument
inacceptable d'utiliser des informations
déjà connues de l'opinion sur lesquels
une route cour de justice de notre pays
il a déjà statué sur ma totale innocence
excluant l'existence de toute
irrégularité ou
après le feu vert de la chambre des
députés contrôlée par l'opposition
c'est désormais au sénat de se prononcer
un vote loin d'être acquis puisque les
opposants au président pinera doivent
obtenir le vote de 29 sénateurs pour que
la procédure de destitution soit engagée
et qu'il ne dispose que de 24 sièges
dans la chambre haute le temps presse le
21 novembre prochain les chiliens
doivent élire un nouveau président et
renouveler leur parlement
restez avec nous dans quelques instants
à nous parlerons de facebook auditions
de frances organes lanceuse d'alert
américaine devant les députés et
sénateurs français aujourd'hui l'ex
employé du réseau social accuse le géant
du web de primes et des jets profits au
détriment de la sécurité
facebook est-il un véritable danger pour
le monde on en parle juste après cette
porte close
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
été formés de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts ni sur
la bbc une charlize des hopitalisés il
était nulle part est ce qu'on peut vivre
malgré cette douleur quand j'ai écrit à
la fois je souffrais parce que ça me
rappelait des beaux souvenirs avec
stéphane en même temps c'était très
douloureux et puis aujourd'hui je me
suis aperçu que ça permettait d'extraire
de de moi même toute cette histoire est
donc ça m'a apporté un peu de recul un
peu d'apaisement mais la douleur est la
couleur seront là jusqu'à ma mort
le volontarisme politique atteint ses
limites dans les français sont de plus
en plus sceptique
[Musique]
avec nous antoine perrut de bonjour
bonjour vous êtes cio comme on disait
dans les grandes entreprises
multinationales de saint gobain russie
ukraine on a beaucoup dit que bon le
l'ouest et caïcos l'eau mais que l'est
et paul vers moi je suis convaincu à
titre personnel que il faut réduire les
émissions de carbone sur la planète
entière donc les plus observés il faut
réduire les émissions de carbone dans
les pays andins bien sûr partout partout
vous avez construit des usines
décarbonés vont des usines roues on
n'aimait rien du tout comme carbone dans
l' usine que ça soit nos émissions
directes ou alors des émissions liées à
la production d'électricité nous en
avons aujourd'hui dans dans le monde
donc là la conscience écologique aussi
existe en russie
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus une pauvre
de défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre le peuple
c'était une volonté collectés vous le
savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il n'y
a pas d'alternative on sort du politique
il est clair que tout le monde attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre de mesures un
peu autoritaire c'est intéressant on
comprend que vous soyez des sous les
libéraux l'uniforme c'est quand même des
hommes comment ces mecs-là arrive à
dormir la nuit là aussi je pense qu'on a
vécu quelque chose d'inouï ce gilet
jaune c'était des valeurs de droite
c'était des gens qui travaillent c'est
des gens qui avaient envie de
transmettre quelque chose à leurs
enfants qui
tout
le droit il doit éviter les dérives
idéologiques merci de le souligner
comment peut-on reconstituer une sixième
république qui ne soit pas de la louve
ligue parlementaire ça se passe en
direct puisque on est on dirait qu'il y
a quand même la liberté je vous remercie
de m'avoir invité
[Musique]
la communication emmanuel macron aux
prêts à des jeunes via twitter instagram
tik tok est ce que depuis sa prise de
fonction c'est devenu son circuit
préférentiel là où avant en tout cas on
avait l'impression que emmanuel macron
avait un contenu politique à nous vendre
une ligne politique des réformes il se
vend comme étant cool et où ça n'a plus
rien fait pour se rapprocher des jeunes
mais parce qu'ils sont beaucoup trop
déconnecté de la sphère politique il
pense que ça va ramener les jeunes à la
politique dont se désintéresserait en
lieu et place de politiser les jeunes ça
dépolitise la politique en la rendant
encore plus qu on est justement c'est
une nouvelle forme de communication
assez verticale utiliser des
influenceurs pour moissac hommes
politiques personnelles est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est vraiment nouveau
d'utiliser des célébrités pour faire de
la propagande politique on s'en fiche
nous on veut quelqu'un qui dirige la
france comme c'est son travail en notre
nom pour nous est dans notre intérêt à
tous
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
coupe
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est 21h merci nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire ce soir facebook est il un
véritable danger pour le monde audition
de frances au gain devant les députés et
sénateurs français
la lanceuse la verte américaine poursuit
sa tournée en europe dans le cadre de
ces révélations sur le fonctionnement
interne du réseau social l'ex employé de
facebook accuse le géant du web de
privilégier le profit au détriment de la
sécurité
quel est votre sentiment pensez vous que
facebook est dangereux pour le monde vos
réactions sur le conte télégramme
berthet france a retrouvé dans le débat
dans quelques instants
elle la lanceuse alerte française au
ghana donc été reçus aujourd'hui par
l'assemblée nationale puis entendu par
le sénat employés j'ai facebook jusqu'en
mai dernier elle accuse son ancien
patron de mettre en péril la démocratie
pour la lanceuse d'alert le géant du web
place le profit avant la sécurité amaya
sous clef
des états unis au royaume uni en passant
par la france la lanceuse d'alert
français saoudienne dresse un tableau à
charge contre le géant facebook
auditionné ce mercredi par la commission
des lois et la commission des affaires
économiques de l'assemblée nationale
la jeune femme accuse notamment le
groupe de mettre en avant des contenus
haineux pour générer plus de clics et
donc plus de profits sauf facebook la
semaine prochaine use the ting tings
en fait facebook a encouragé les gens à
rejoindre des groupes depuis des années
et ces groupes sont sélectionnés en
fonction d'un classement basé sur
l'engagement et par conséquent l'année
dernière il ya eu un scandale 65% des
personnes en allemagne ont rejoint des
groupes nazis en allemagne en allemagne
parce que facebook souhaite que vous
restiez plus longtemps sur la plateforme
seafrance et saoudienne appelle à réagir
face à cette pratique elle appelle
également employer plus de modérateur
francophone pour faire face aux propos
haineux violent et raciste
le système français n'est pas aussi
développé que celui des etats-unis ou de
l'angleterre
des modérateurs défaillant déjà pointé
du doigt grâce au document interne que
frances à hogan avait fait fuiter il y a
quelques mois elle dénonce également un
secret de polichinelle au sein de
facebook et la firme était selon elle au
courant de l'aspect nuisibles de ses
activités mais a décidé de fermer les
yeux afin de ne pas impacter ses revenus
ok d'autres plateformes importantes
représente un risque pour les sociétés
et pour notre démocratie il faut que ces
entreprises puissent rendre des comptes
et il faut également des nouvelles
règles dans ce business model
et facebook ne peut pas rester jury
juges procureurs et témoin à la fois
donc le point de départ ici c'est la
transparence
son témoignage intervient en pleine
régulation européenne sur la
responsabilisation des réseaux sociaux
et la modération des contenus et en même
temps qu'une proposition de loi des
députés français pour renforcer la
protection des lanceurs d'alerté qu'elle
a salué lors de sa prise de parole
d informations n en ligne ou encore
fragilisation de l' équilibre familial
il n'y a pas que franz à hogan qui tire
la sonnette d'alarmé une note interne de
facebook montrent que le réseau social
serait à l'origine de bien des maux plus
d'explications avec des villes khalifa
être esclave de la modernité être
esclave de cette petite icône sur votre
téléphone peut avoir des répercussions
dangereuses sur votre quotidien ce n'est
pas moi qui le dit mais bien facebook
lui-même une étude interne reprise par
le wall street journal révèle 40
utilisateurs sur 8 déclarent faire un
usage ou pulls cif du réseau social
les conséquences sont nombreuses et
néfaste pour la santé commençons par un
fait simple vous êtes dans votre livre
vous ne trouvez pas le sommeil premier
réflexe prendre son smartphone appuyé
sur son application bleus et faire
défiler le fil d'actu c'est ce qu'on
appelle du ce meilleur mois est
automatiquement une perte de
productivité le lendemain que ce soit au
travail ou pour toute autre activité
autre exemple démontré par cette étude
la dégradation des relations
personnelles c'est à dire remplacer le
temps passé ensemble par des heures
voire plus en ligne
la ville famille s'en trouve fortement
impactée notamment pour les parents
dans certains cas les parents se
concentrer davantage sur facebook que
sur les soins apportés ou à la
communication avec leurs enfants les
effets pervers de l'utilisation à
outrance du réseau social dans la maison
mère s'appelle désormais meta
concernerait près de 360 millions
d'utilisateurs dans le monde ces
nouvelles révélations s'inscrivent dans
la lignée des facebook files des
articles basés sur des documents
internes fournis par la lanceuse alerte
française à google c'est ancien employé
du département civique integrity chargée
de lutter contre l'effet que news
montrent que meta consacre davantage de
ressources à limiter ses effets néfastes
en occident au détriment du reste du
monde des conséquences connues en
interne mais les signaux d'alerté ne
sont pas toujours pris en compte en
témoigne cette étude de 2010 est réalisé
par une équipe axée sur le bien-être
cette même équipe avait suggéré des
solutions pour limiter ces usages
problématiques
mais cette section était dissoute par à
mark zuckerberg en 2019 ces usages le
wall street journal n'a pas peur des
mots il est qualifié de dépendance un
terme qui fait bondir le groupe une
utilisation problématique n'est pas
synonyme de dépendances le wall street
journal a de nouveau choisi de manière
sélective des documents internes de
l'entreprise pour présenter un récit qui
est tout simplement faux sur la façon
dont nous utilisons la recherche pour
aborder un problème important
notre entreprise s'est engagée et
soutient les efforts à plusieurs niveaux
pour mieux comprendre et responsabiliser
les personnes qui utilisent nos services
pour gérer les utilisations
problématique en pleine tourmente
meta doit affronter bon nombre de
révélations depuis plus d'un mois dans
la presse gestion discrétionnaire des
profils vieilles pies ah non soumis aux
mêmes règles que les autres effets
pervers des algorithmes de
recommandation ou encore cette
accusation de privilégier le profit à la
santé des utilisateurs
une affaire dont 100 par les
parlementaires aux états unis et
ailleurs français saoudienne mène ce
combat elle vole d'une audition à
l'autre après washington londres le
parlement européen ce lundi elle sera ce
mercredi à l'assemblée et au sénat signe
d'une véritable prise de conscience de
la part des politiques
je suis heureuse que l'union européenne
prenne cette question très au sérieux
le digital services act qui est
actuellement examiné par le parlement a
le potentiel pour devenir une référence
mondiale ça peut inspirer d'autres pays
dont le mien à prendre en charge de
nouvelles prérogatives afin de protéger
nos démocraties
français saoudienne va même plus loin
dans son analyse la lanceuse dallaire
considère que les ingénieurs de facebook
ne sont même plus en mesure de gérer les
changements d'algorithme du réseau
social comme si la créature échapper à
son créateur une métaphore pleine de
sens reprise par de nombreux médias et
tout cela était pourtant prévisible
quand on se souvient du scandale
cambridge analytica en 2018 cette firme
de marketing politique avait été accusé
d'avoir volé les données de 87 millions
d'utilisateurs de facebook pour tenter
de les influencer par des messages au
trump ou pro briques site un signal d'
alerte pas toujours pris en compte par
les politiques à l'époque aujourd'hui la
donne a changé et urgent c'est de
comprendre les effets systémiques des
réseaux sociaux en général et de
facebook en particulier reste à savoir
si ce n'est pas trop tard on vient de le
constater donc facebook qui traverse ces
d'un étang une fils de réputation majeur
mais tu as la maison mère a donc décidé
de rectifier le tir on en parle avec
notre correspondant à washington thomas
bonnin bonsoir thomas facebook qui va
donc retirée prochainement des
catégories jugées sensibles du ciblage
publicitaire
oui c'est la dernière étape en date pour
facebook ou plutôt devrais-je dire pour
meta de tenter de redorer son image
jusqu'à présent les annonceurs peuvent
cibler très précisément leur audience
pour les publicités qui sont diffusés
sur la plateforme facebook avec
notamment des milles et deux catégories
qui sont disponibles pour affiner la
pertinence de ces publicités et bien
désormais à certaines catégories jugées
sensibles vont être retirés par facebook
notamment celles autour de l'orientation
sexuelle des problèmes de santé des
pratiques religieuses ou encore des
affiliations politiques les annonceurs
ne pourront donc plus utiliser ces
catégories pour atteindre à un certain
public facebook dit avoir pris cette
décision suite au retour d'un certain
nombre d'experts en droits civiques une
décision dont facebook a c'est qu'elle
aura forcément un impact pour les
entreprises écoutez un extrait du
communiqué publié par facebook justement
la décision de retirer ses options de
ciblage publicitaire n'était pas simple
et nous savons que ce changement
pourrait impacter négativement certaines
entreprises nous sommes confiants quant
au fait que nous pouvons faire évoluer
notre système de publicité pour être en
adéquation avec les besoins de chacun
tout en travaillant avec application
pour continuer à soutenir une des
meilleures choses de notre plateforme
aider les gens à se connecter et à
découvrir les entreprises et les
organisations qui les intéressent alors
vous l'avez entendu facebook se veut
quand même optimiste parce qu'il ya
encore des milliers de catégories qui
reste accessible et la publicité ciblée
encore de beaux jours devant elle cette
mise à jour aura lieu le 19 janvier 2022
on comprend que c'est une décision qui
s'inscrit dans la tentative de facebook
de redorer son image après la fuite de
documents internes après les révélations
de cet ancien employé lanceuse d' alerte
qui affirme que facebook privilégie son
profit au détriment d'une régulation des
propos haineux et violent des
accusations qui vous l'avez entendu on
trouvait un fort écho dans les médias du
monde entier alors malgré un changement
de nom et un changement de politique en
matière de publicité ciblée pas sûr que
cela suffise pour que facebook sortent
enfin dans la controverse dans laquelle
elle est plongée depuis maintenant
plusieurs mois voire même plusieurs
années si thomas bonnet vous restez avec
nous s'il vous plaît puisque on va aller
plus loin avec nos invités se posait la
question suivante facebook est il un
danger pour le monde on attend vos
réactions toujours sur le conte
télégramme d'ayrté france et c'est
l'heure donc de notre décryptage
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler en direct donc
cyrielle civile pardon d'helmand
chercheur à l'institut thomas more
bonsoir série-là d'allemands merci
d'être avec nous sur ce plateau avec
nous monsieur kim yu-na vocal chercheur
spécialiste des problématiques liées à
l'économie du numérique est donc
toujours en tome abonnés qui nous
accompagne depuis washington
si lille d'allemands la lanceuse d'
alerte à frances hogan ex employé de
facebook y assure donc que le réseau
social affaibli les démocraties rien que
ça c'est très fort comme accusation ça
vous semble pertinent
pertinents c'est difficile à dire
l'impact des réseaux sociaux devient
majeur dans l'expression démocratique
d'ailleurs lors de sa censure de la loi
via le conseil constitutionnel français
parle justement d'un droit d'accès aux
réseaux sociaux
donc il ya un impact majeur sur
l'expression démocratique
après vous il ya quand même une vision
politique
qui n'est pas neutre dans l'appréciation
du rôle de facebook quant à son
danger potentiel au niveau des
démocraties c'est à dire chacun
l'interprétera comme comme il l'entend
il ya en france notamment le
gouvernement français travaille avec
facebook depuis de 2019 sur la
régulation
de certains messages de ce qu'on
qualifie de fair use
donc ça s'inscrit dans une démarche
assez longue
aux états unis on a tous le phénomène du
romantisme
kiki aussi vient impacter
cette appréciation de la vérité en fait
je suis pas un grand défenseur de faits
de boue mais il faut quand même
reconnaître que chacun a tendance à
orienter
l'impact que pourrait avoir un réseau
social par rapport à sa propre vérité
alors mathieu quiniou français se
gagnent en tout cas ne soit revenir
clairement à des des réseaux à l'échelle
humaine dit jusqu'en 2008 ça et s était
acceptable qu est-ce qui a changé
justement depuis les années 2008 2009 ce
sont ces fameux hyper amplificateur qui
favoriserait un discours haineux en tout
cas on est sur des méta plate forme
maintenant et qui sont vraiment
dominante on est passé d'un modèle où
finalement les mass-médias dominé et ces
structures là qui sont des réseaux
sociaux venez progressivement prendre
aussi des départs de marché départ de
lisibilité mais on a vu par exemple dans
les dernières campagnes présidentielles
la place que représentait les réseaux
sociaux en termes mêmes de limitation de
temps de parole en terme de censure donc
c'est vraiment devenus des acteurs
centraux au niveau démocratique et on
voit aussi la manière dont les marchés
en terme publicitaire aussi vont
s'orienter vers ce type de profil âge
puisque ça permet de toucher une
audience bien plus précise donc c'est
aussi plus intéressant donc ils sont
devenus tellement structurants dans nos
sociétés donc oui en tout cas ce qu elle
pointe du doigt elle sait que facebook
pousse délibérément ses utilisateurs à
rejoindre ces grands groupes de
discussion des à des fins commerciales
et comme elle le dit générateur de
discours haineux est-ce que c'est
véritablement le cas ces îles -
c'est difficile à dire encore une fois
je
doudou en parle c'est à dire qu'un
message et nous c'est très compliqué à
qualifier juridiquement
ça dépend de la personne qu'il
interprète après que facebook isole
volontairement
les utilisateurs dans des groupes
conforme à leur mode de pensée et les
visuels les uns des autres pour créer en
fait d espèce de clone qui qui qui
vivrait qu'entre c'est c'est une
évidence et au niveau marketing c'est ça
s'explique très bien puisque ça provoque
au sein de ces groupes des impulsions
d'achat des modes et d'une espèce de
segmentation la consommation
alors autre point de vue qui est un
petit peu discuté qui interroge cette
lanceuse des leurs qui plaide une fois
de plus pour que facebook soit contraint
aussi de rendre public et les données
qu'il détient justement sur
l'utilisation de son service
clairement on peut parler m e qui
doutent d'une entreprise avec un
fonctionnement extrêmement opaque bien
sûr les les black box est un vrai souci
1 comprend de l'algorithme de
hiérarchisation aussi comment est ce que
les finalement les profilages sont faits
pourquoi on nous envoie telle ou telle
information avoir une visibilité sur ça
c'est un vrai enjeu est d'ailleurs au
niveau européen on voit qu'il ya une
recherche de réglementation il ya une
réglementation en cours au niveau de
l'intelligence artificielle qui
toucheraient bien évidemment facebook et
qui permettrait justement de d'éviter
aussi certains usages de l'intelligence
artificielle pour du profilage avec des
débits et discriminatoire qui
permettrait d'éviter ce type de choses
là et d'avoir aussi éventuellement une
visibilité sur le code pour que les
citoyens puissent se positionner en et
les consommateurs voilà selon la manière
dont on est appréhendée aussi par par
ces structures thomas bonnin washington
le rôle de facebook et et là bas aussi
régulièrement questionnée un aux états
unis
les différentes les démocrates comme les
républicains veulent s'attaquer
justement à l'encadrement juridique de
facebook il faut comprendre qu aux etats
unis facebook est régi par une loi qui
s'appelle la section 230 et qui comprend
en fait deux aspects d'abord à les
plateformes numériques dont facebook
contrairement aux journaux ne peuvent
pas être tenu responsable du contenu qui
circulent et puis l'autre aspect c'est
qu'elles ont le droit de modérer à leur
guise le contenu en le signalant en
ajoutant des investissements etc c'est
sur ce point précisément que donald
trump avait voulu attaquer les
plateformes numériques notamment après
que certains de ces messages a lui été
signalée sur la plateforme twitter alors
que pour les démocrates c'est plutôt le
premier volet de cette loi qui pose
problème car il estime que cela laisse
libre cours à des contenus qu'il
qualifie de désinformation c'est
d'ailleurs aussi ce qui explique la
lanceuse d'alert française à horgen qui
elle aussi veut s'attaquer veut amender
cette cette section de 130 notamment
pour que facebook soit tenu responsable
des algorithmes qui sont utilisées et
qui favorise certains contenus au
détriment d'autres on va aller voir les
premiers messages 1 parce que
comme le disait notre invité tout à
l'heure à cyril d'helmand c'est toujours
du point de vue là on se place les
téléspectateurs eux soulève beaucoup la
question de la censure ça c'est ce qui
revient dans beaucoup de messages
télégramme envoyé sur le conte
télégramme rt france est un danger car
ce média choisi qui a le droit de parole
et surtout qui oriente l'opinion
message avec ses positions et ses
idéologies prompt à la censure est
interdit tout débat pourtant
démocratique le réseau est détourné pour
utiliser et servir de propagande est oui
facebook sang sur tout ce qui sort de
son cercle l'autre jour et non censuré
une publication sur trump qui datait
d'il ya un an thomas justement on vous
retrouvera rapidement avant de redonner
la parole à nos invités donald trump est
précisément avaient crié à l'ascension
sur les réseaux sociaux d'où il a été
d'ailleurs banni à tel point qu'il a
lancé sa propre plateforme
où les républicains aux états unis
parlent beaucoup de la censure des
géants du numérique il faut dire que
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu une accélération
ces dernières années sur différents
sujets évidemment sur la campagne
présidentielle américaine sur les
évènements au capitole le siège en mai
dernier ou encore plus récemment sur le
co vide 19 alors pour les républicains
aux états unis il est clair que les
géants du numérique ciblent davantage
les figures on va dire conservateur
conservative du paysage politique
américain ils ont d'ailleurs déposé un
projet de loi au mois de juillet dernier
justement pour tenter de modifier
l'encadrement de ces médiations opéré
par les plateformes et l'une de leurs
oppositions et notamment pour permettre
de pouvoir contester la décision lorsque
son compte et censuré c'est le cas
donald trump on sait d'ailleurs que
l'ancien président a porté plainte au
mois de juillet dernier contre facebook
twitter mais aussi google pour tenter de
récupérer ses comptes vu que ça semble
assez mal embarquée pour lui il a donc
décidé de lancer sa plateforme qui sera
disponible dit on au courant de l'année
2022 il faudra voir si les personnes qui
iront sur la plateforme de l'ancien
locataire de la maison blanche seront
assez nombreux et surtout est ce qu il
s'agira surtout de supporters de donald
trump ou si cette plateforme va aussi
pouvoir convaincre d'autres utilisateurs
merci à thomas bonnet cyril dalle bon là
on en revient c'est du point de vue où
là on se place mais effectivement
ça en est l'illustration ce quatre
hommes en fait on a exactement le même
process en france il faut savoir que
facebook juste que j'expliquais travail
avec le gouvernement français depuis
2009 avec une logique de diminution
alors en fait pour contourner l'aspect
censure tue tout de suite génère un
certain nombre de réactions facebook
s'est orienté sur une limitation de la
viralité autrement dit elle isole un
commentaire un message d'une publication
et diminue la capacité à ce qu'on
appelle d'un reportage donc où une
relecture fait baisser le la capacité
virale d'un message et il ya des choix
qui sont clairement affichées à par
facebook tout à l'heure je parlais du
lotissement des ces choix sont clairs
la limite de viralité concernent des
thématiques de société qui sont à
l'immigration l'islam
la gpa la pma on est vraiment dans une
philosophie qui avait assumé en fait par
le réseau social
c'est un peu par dans matthieu quiniou
comment juridiquement on peut lutter
contre ces travers de censure qui ont
l'air de choquer pas mal d'utilisateurs
la question de la censure se pose
réellement 1 effectivement il ya déjà
quand même un cadre légal qui permet de
lutter contre la censure mais on efface
quand même des nouveaux acteurs et ça
peut passer aussi par un croisement
entre le droit et la normalisation
technique et donc la possibilité
de de structurellement regarder ces
algues au rythme là et faire en sorte
que à partir du moment où on va décider
que tel contenu ne devrait plus être
publié parce que il touche à telle ou
telle et telle est l élément parce qu'il
ya un hashtag spécifiques ou des
éléments prin d'excès que ce soit
totalement mis de côté et qu'on ait une
vraie lisibilité donc ça peut être aussi
fait techniquement c'est à dire par des
ingénieurs qui vont regarder le code
audités ça et faire en sorte que soient
compatibles avec le droit alors autres
inquiétudes que soulèvent française au
ghana le porte sur le projet en deux du
géant américain dans le métavers sens on
va apprendre à beaucoup parler d'eux de
cela cette doublure numérique du monde
physique où l'entreprise entrevoit
d'immenses possibilités commerciales je
vous propose d'écouter la lanceuse
d'alert
winston et le métavers est une question
très préoccupante à mon avis je pense
que leur vision d'être au sein de
l'environnement de travail est très
préoccupante ils veulent de capteurs des
micros des systèmes de surveillance mais
imaginez que vous êtes chez vous que
vous travaillez de chez vous et que
votre employeur décide d'être une
entreprise de mai s'avère et bien c'est
problématique car vous êtes au sein de
votre cadre personnel hors des micros
pourront être placés dans ce cadre
personnel et c'est un gros problème
la série tellement effectivement ce
metaverse qui nous fait si peur ce qu'on
a raison de s'inquiéter comme le fait un
français surviennent alors est-ce qu'on
a raison oui on a raison il faut bien
comprendre que la logique du metavers en
fait c'est la numérisation du corps à
une irradiation de l'individu pour
partir c'est le premier pas dans la
logique transhumanistes la disparition
du corps physique
[Musique]
l'englobé l'intégralité des activités
d'un individu au travers de son clown
numérique est en fait cette logique elle
et elle est très très mercantile parce
que on est sur une belgique d'addiction
c'est à dire que vous passerez des
heures et des heures et des heures au
travers du metavers avec votre double
numérique dont votre avatar numérique et
vous serez totalement isolé du monde
réel cette logique d'isoler l'individu
du monde réel à elle est fondamentale
pour ses réseaux sociaux qu'est-ce que
plus vous allez passer tant sur le
réseau social plus potentiellement on va
pouvoir vous analysez analyser vos
intentions d'achat deviner vos futurs
achats en fait on va on va réaliser une
carte complète numérique de ce que vous
êtes pour en connaître mieux que à la
nuit de vous reconnaissez vous même
c'est c'est là où c'est terrible mais on
est on est dans la logique de
l'addiction mais ça veut dire parce que
là vous fait un petit peu peur on a
l'impression d'être dans un vieux film
de enfin d'un vieux film de science
fiction
ça veut dire quoi qu'on va vivre qu'on
va habiter combat louer des appartements
virtuellement on va conduire des
voitures virtuel le monde réel
n'existera pjd pour bien là la saisir un
ca de vous faire rêver votre vie là si
on va au bout de la démarche du metavers
sait faire rêver l'individu une vie qui
est numérique donc il se détache de la
médiocrité de son existence de ces
problèmes du quotidien pour
partir dans un monde virtuel dans lequel
il pourra être n'importe quel acteur il
pourra vivre une vie totalement
différente s'ils habitent dans une tour
de béton à 100 paysage on pourra le
projeter sur une île paradisiaque et du
coup il aura besoin pour continuer à
vivre cette vie numérique de pratiquer
des achats
inclut bien sûr ce type de réseau vont
mettre en place notamment des voyages
virtuels des billets d'avion virtuelle
des voitures virtuel du carburant
habituel avec une monnaie virtuelle
et vous vivrez dans un rêve permanent
bon le canal j étais la charge par mois
on aura peut-être pu elle paye et
mathieu quiniou c'est vraiment je dirais
familièrement un petit peu flippant
juridiquement est ce que il ya des
paraphes us qu'on va en arriver là
sans aucun contrepoids juridiques
notamment alors on avait vu par exemple
que le projet libre à qui est devenu jam
a quand même été régulée même vraiment
limité par les américains par le
gouvernement donc ça ça a été mis un
petit peu de côté donc ça aurait été un
pan fait de facebook dans le domaine
bancaire là on arrive sur un autre champ
qui à mon sens relève plus quand même du
loisir qui est moins inquiétant mais
bien sûr des données pourront être
obtenus ça peut toucher au monde du
travail aussi on l'a vu avec les visio
conférences qui se généralise et le fed
finalement d'avoir tout un pan de son
activité qui est devenu entièrement
numérisée et je pense que facebook
regarde de près aussi ce qui se fait au
niveau de la blocs shane et on a vu
l'apparition à la fois des jetons au
fonds gip dnf t&d métavers décentraliser
les ces marchés là commence à prendre et
facebook essaie de se renouveler sans
aucune réglementation évidemment pour
l'instant tu dis en un petit peu c'est
une réglementation des marchés
financiers une règlementation voir aussi
en chine par exemple que le temps
d'usagé pour le loisir sur internet a
été limitée et la chine a une stratégie
aussi à la facebook je sais pas qui
copie qui mais il ya une logique de 10
dans de double numérique qui est
proposée en chine pour faire une sorte
de méta vers cette fois ci ils n'ont pas
contrôlé par métal une méta plateforme
une entreprise mais parler n'est pas un
état merci
mathieu qui nous remercient cyril
allemand d'avoir été avec nous merci
également notre correspondant à
washington thomas baudet de nous avoir
accompagnés merci à vous croire et c'est
la fin de cette émission rendez vous
demain ce sera avec samantha rameau amis
pour le 20h donc et pour moi je mets le
plaisir de vous retrouver évidemment
lundi l'actualité continue toute la
soirée sur arte france
[Musique]
il n'y a pas une façon plus pauvres de
défendre un système que de dire qu'il
est moins pire qu'un autre la peuplent
c'était une volonté collective
vous savez pour moi que dès qu'on dit il
n'y a pas d'alternative on sort du
politique il est clair que tout le monde
attend ça
est-ce que c'est grave est ce que c'est
normal si on veut sauver la vie sur
terre il est probable qu'il faille
prendre un certain nombre